boris johnson is going to lay out his
roadmap for a relaxing lockdown next
monday
and he's got a new three-part slogan
data not
dates so let's take a look at the data
last month there was a worry because the
biggest testing study in england showed
cases still at very high levels
its latest results came out on thursday
and take a look
they showed cases falling really far
especially in london
and also in the southeast other data
shows the same pattern now this chart
shows the results from the
office for national statistics survey
dating all the way back to may
if you look over here you can see it is
now falling
really quite fast which is good news
although
it is still at a relatively high level
it's a lot higher than when school
starts to reopen after the first
lockdown
is it too soon to make the same move
someone who thinks it's not is the first
minister of wales and this is the
situation in wales according to the ons
you can see it's very similar to england
and mark drakeford just announced today
that despite this picture children under
seven
will go back from monday and this
is exactly what he should be doing
according to the man behind this chart
our old friend tony blair his institute
has laid out criteria for reopening
measured by the r and cases per 100 000.
the art across the uk is under one and
in wales cases per 100
000 are 84 which puts them at level four
so according to tony blair it's time for
them
to reopen schools retail level three
might come soon after
but hospitality for that you need cases
under 10. so
according to tony blair that's some way
off
now you might be wondering what tony
blair has to do with all of this
he's not a scientist he's not even in
the government but he
is someone that the current government
listens to
and this framework has one really big
advantage
it answers the tough question of
regional variation
what happens if case sahin leads but low
in leicester
it's basically the old tier model with a
bit
more precision more data less dates
don't be too surprised if you see
something similar from boris johnson
on monday